hi and welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and you have to have
seen black panther rocana Forever by now
if you haven't just just stop the damn
video stop the damn video go see it I'll
even let you use my AMC pass afterwards
come back and tell me how much you love
Dominic Thorns River Williams I loved
all the characters but ReRe stole all
the attention when the camera was on her
she's just so funny smart witty hard
working this girl killed it and we know
we'll be seeing her in Iron Heart series
coming late 2023 but what can we expect
to see from that child prodigy genius
from now until then what's next for Riri
Williams I ask so in this video I'll
break down the different paths we can
take knowing what we know from Nancy you
and as always sprinkling in some of that
comic book facts that I know I'm a nerd
for those that don't know Riri Williams
is a Super Genius incredibly smart she's
an engineer inventor mathematician
literally all of the above everything I
am not in the comics she's built her
first armor suit from an outdated Iron
Man suit so you can see the resemblance
it's no surprise that these two cross
paths her and Iron Man seen as they're
both engineer inventors that are
incredibly smart once riri's suit was
destroyed she repaired it and fought
alongside Iron Man in the second Civil
War we know from wakanda Forever that
the MCU Ruby Williams is a Chicago
native studying at MIT is creating an
iron man-like suit the blueprints to a
machine that can find vibranium and
every sort of encryption-based computer
harboring all of her inventions this may
be her introduction but definitely not
her origin story which leads me to path
number one ironheart's return to MIT
this is sort of a two-parter because I
think she'll go to MIT first then back
to Chicago because in an interview with
Marvel producer Nate Moore in regards to
iron Hearts Riri Williams after wakanda
forever he says her Adventure in the
movie and coming out on the other end of
it with her experiences really motivates
her to become more of a hero because of
what she's seen but she's going to find
out in the show not to spoil anything
that's easier to do in wakanda with
wakanda behind you than it is as of now
20 or 21 year old student who goes back
to MIT which I think is like the full
synopsis of Iron Heart she's going to be
our new Iron Man Marvel producer Nate
Moore has also confirmed that really
Williams ironheart will be a direct
sequel to Black Panther wakanda forever
so what we last Saw of her wakanda will
directly slide into the ironheart series
so I suspect Val will continue to have
her eyes on reread to either a grab one
of her suits or B grab her for the
Thunderbolts unfortunately Riri did
assist in destroying a bunch of cop cars
on the bridge and escaping an arrest so
she's technically most likely wanted and
the first place to scout her is her dorm
at MIT I think that he will be on her
and she'll take the first ticket home to
see her mom after everything happened in
wakanda Forever which takes me to our
sub pack ironhearts return to Chicago
she mentions in the movie Just wanting
to see her mom after being America's
wakandas and the talokin's most wanted I
suspect going back home to Chicago is
one of the top places she'd want to be I
think this is when we get some
resemblance to An Origin story we know
her stepfather passed and in the comics
she lost her father and best friend
Natalie in a drive-by shooting during a
picnic this was really hard for her in
the comics and clearly the thing she
learned from her dad translated to
sorrowful memories in wakanda forever as
well her dad's car where she first
learned a bill Etc we'll probably see
more of how important her family friends
and truly everyone in Chicago is to her
and some slight flashbacks of retellings
by the way hunting for Easter eggs in
your favorite show or movie that's fun
hunting for malware and old system logs
on your Mac Oh horrible that's a job you
want done for you which is why there's
clean my Mac X clean my Mac X is the
best software on the market to clean and
optimize your Mac it deletes Mega tons
of junk malware uninstalls unused apps
which I severely need and makes Mac
computers faster safer and more
organized it's so good that it's been
notarized by Apple themselves and if
it's not arrives by Apple no it's good
and if anybody knows how to keep a Mac
clean it's probably the people that
build it I assume right I mean I hope
clean my Mac X has a whole bunch of
tools you can use to clean up your Mac
smart scan find system files you no
longer need space lens will show you
what files are taking up the most room
on your hard drive and malware removal
will find all those nasty little viruses
and junk programs you didn't even know
you had the little ones that go like
it's like little rats it's like rats and
once your Mac is healthy clean my Mac
X's menu app will help you keep it
healthy by giving you an easy way to
look at Key performance indicators of
your computer because God knows I don't
understand what's going on no wonder
clean my Mac X has been an industry
leader in Mac health for 14 years and
he's used by millions of people in 185
countries around the world plus
Antarctica I guess they don't normally
count to get started making your Mac run
like new just click the link in the
description to download clean my Mac X
today we know Natalie will be making an
appearance as some casting updates have
already dropped lyric Ross is playing
the best friend who I assume is Natalie
Anthony Ramos is the hood and of course
we've heard the rumors of Sasha bear
Cohen playing Mephisto there's a lot of
others like Harper Anthony Manny Montana
Jay Cooley and Chris summers in an
undisclosed role and others but this
leads me to our second path more of like
a sub path to path one subpath number
two Iron Heart versus the hood remember
earlier when I mentioned Riri destroying
her suit so it was destroyed when she
intercepted a couple of inmates when she
stopped their escape vehicle now I'm not
saying that exact thing will happen
along the same lines but from the comics
the hood was into loads of crime he's
created by Brian K Vaughn and Kyle Holtz
so yeah the crime was pretty dark at
times and the hood AKA Parker Robbins
was always into this light it started
with stealing money to take care of his
mom then to straight up robberies that
didn't stop once he became a super
villain because you know supervillains
like we'll leave that stuff and try to
take over the world no he kept robbing
people which
I mean I probably do I feel it Parker
and his brother planned to rob a
warehouse and walked in on a ritual
where they are attacked by the demon
Asante Parker shot and killed nasanti
and stole his Red Cloak and boots that
at the time he didn't know were
empowered by dormammu and he dipped out
I think we can expect something like
that for the hood but this time maybe
making a deal with our favorite fake
hell spawn Mephisto in order to get the
cloaking boots winnoma Fisto likes to
make deals literally head over to Screen
Rant they actually have a list on every
deal he's ever made with people but also
we know that he's brainwashed tricked
and manipulated people into doing his
work for him so the hood could be making
a deal on Mephisto maybe to help his mom
saving another family member or just to
gain more power and Mephisto loving
tricks and wanting his soul probably
sees him as a qualified vessel this all
happening before or even after ironheart
intercepts inmates it's no surprise that
the hood wants to take her down which we
cue the technology vs demonic magic
fights which leads me to subpath number
three ironheart finds help in her peers
she's got the tech but does she have the
hell demon magic no one does who else
goes to MIT Ned Lee and MJ we know after
Spider-Man no way home the two were
admitted into MIT along with along with
the Flash oh God the hole that Riri has
on the MIT students underground homework
ring wouldn't surprise me that she's
created something that can search some
sort of like database using the MIT
Wi-Fi for keywords like magic and come
across our little sling ringer net or we
know MJ was working hard to get money
and no way home she could be under the
same admission as Riri if any could you
even imagine if those two were actually
roommates and we just never saw who the
other roommate was in the dorm and it
was actually MJ because they're both
like robotics oh okay I'm a nerd I know
that the con here we have no Insight on
their contracts with MCU just yet so
there's always another possible Pier
Cassie Lang I've been writing this
theory for a minute the person that
helped build the schematics for Cassie's
device in quantumania is someone via the
Internet I think and it could be Iron
Lab yes but I think it could be reuber
Williams and Voss teases exactly what I
was theorizing in his breakdown of
wakanda forever play the clip they go to
riri's Warehouse where she said she had
to build a quantum computer to crack her
her own encryption Quantum you say I
mean the future of technology in the MCU
is certainly Quantum Riri actually could
have been the friend who helped Cassie
Lang build that Quantum Tech that leads
to all them getting sucked into the
quantum realm in Quantum media Quantum
Quantum Quantum Quantum see Riri said
there's videos of her online testing her
suit maybe Cassie reached out after
seeing those on YouTube now see
is a spiritual more demonic being in the
comics I'd assume she'd start
researching how to defeat someone like
this which could Point her in the
direction of the Mystic Arts and
reaching out to someone like Juan we
know from She-Hulk he's outwardly very
proud of his position and makes it
seemingly easy to reach him if Wong is
busy watching this is us maybe he
encourages or recommends America Chavez
they already have a lot in common I mean
they both were hunted down almost killed
by super powered human beings so that
doesn't just happen every day their
stories are identical almost I think
she'll enlist someone's help I mean they
always do and they always should
Teamwork Makes the Dream Work right
because from wakanda Forever she has
engineering down but now she's up
against demonic magic which might need
more convincing I prefer it to be Ned
and MJ because it's written in the stars
for them to meet all at MIT but I think
the potential for a little crossover
literally from any of the young Geniuses
of the MCU is a good working Theory even
the the older people of the MCU she's
gonna need a lawyer so She-Hulk
Daredevil get in there that's some other
things just some of the things I've been
speculating because there's so much
there's rumors about obadiah's son
showing up I just brought up the lawyers
there's so so much that could happen to
reread next she's worked with so many
people from the comics and the young
superheroes entering the MCU aren't
stopping here let me know in the
comments where you think she's headed
next and what we should look out for
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Lulu underscore Clemens follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching now go read Champion
get out of here I'm a nerd
[Music]